[Music]
hello everyone welcome i'm paul cowling
i'm the associate director of education
at film independent and i welcome you to
our next virtual coffee talk for those
who don't know us film independent is a
non-profit arts based organization in
los angeles a mission is to champion
creative independence in visual
storytelling and support community of
artists who embody diversity innovation
and uniqueness of vision memberships
open to everyone you can find out more
about us at film independent org emerald
socials just look film independent on
facebook twitter and instagram but today
it's a virtual coffee talk with two of
our favorite filmmakers do these intros
and then hand over that today and i'll
be back later on for some Q&A
so first up she's the director of the
seminal indie gil fight which was a
Spirit Award nominee for Best first
feature and then she went made Ian flux
Jennifer's Body the invitation and
destroyer and she's also very well known
for her TV career she's directed
episodes of some of today's hottest TV
shows including the man in the high
castle and catch fire billions and most
recently HBO's super super creepy The
Outsider and she's also an active board
member of film independent so welcome to
current through summer make sure you are
on camera yeah
can you guys just yes there you go
welcome thanks for doing this car yes
thank you it's great it's really fun to
do this funny a time when I asked you to
do this and who you wanted to chat to
you said I'd love to chat to our other
guest here he's the director of brick
which was a Spirit Award nominee for the
John Cassavetes award best films made
under half a million dollars he also
made the Brothers Bloom the Mindbender
looper
which of course snagged him to direct
Star Wars Episode eight the last Jedi
and most his most recent film is knives
out which is his homage to the Agatha
Christie murder mystery genres
he's also directed three episodes of the
classic now modern classic Breaking Bad
including what I think is one of the
most intense hours of television ever
that was the manliest episode so please
welcome Ron Johnson hello hey hey so um
firstly my first question to you before
we had it over to current is like just
how you doing in this new crazy world
we're living in I mean weird we're doing
great my wife and I are both you know in
writing mode so it's where it's strange
how our lives on the surface haven't
actually changed much and yet there's
this weird psychological weights over
the fact that we're sitting home all day
not seeing people but we're doing just
fine and we're healthy and our families
are all healthy and you know that's the
only thing that really matters I'm doing
pretty well I mean I think again yeah
I'm in a similar place as Ryan and that
I'm in a generative place right now so
this I try to look at this time as an
opportunity but it's really easy to get
pretty pretty despairing if you read the
news too frequently so I'm trying to
kind of balance my my you know tendrils
out to the outside world and enjoy the
isolation for what it what it could be
right so I'm gonna step back here and
let you guys chat in these sort of
coffee talk modes kind of just talk shop
and I'll be back in about minutes with
some questions okay great thank you
mm-hmm thanks Bryan hey Karan you doing
I'm pretty good I'm pretty good
so you're writing are you how you doing
really that's a good question I mean I
um I feel I just to be perfectly honest
I need to have moments where I do check
in with what's really happening and I
have to say that it can get pretty
emotional for me just to feel that you
know I'm really facing the moment of
sort of my good fortune my all the
privileges that come with having a roof
over your head and not having to worry
about dinner and not having to worry you
know like that stuff is it's just so
profound and so I've been thinking a lot
about a broken system that's been
powering America for the past 40 years
but I'm just trying to understand how to
be a part of change you know right yeah
but I'm also we were talking about her
sourdough starter I'm like I mean I'm
trying to like embrace the time and and
and embrace what's possible in this
moment right now you know there's a lot
of like focus that's coming that BEC
that we could be taking advantage of
right now so I'm trying to I'm trying to
work with that energy as well yeah yeah
yeah that's a good thing to focus on
yeah yeah it's yeah the idea it's uh it
should be a time own are you finding
yourself a really creative right now or
because I'm finding it kind of a grind
it's hard I'm not gonna lie it's hard
but it's interesting because I have a
bunch of projects at different stages
and one of them for instance is limited
series adaptation of a novel and I'm not
writing it but I'm I'm about to start a
sort of kind of overview process with
the writer and so I'm rereading the
novel with broaden strokes in mind about
visual inspiration haematic
overlap it's a very broad epic story and
so it's been really interesting to have
to just sort of think about associations
visually between completely different
storylines and how to build visual
transitions because I think that's such
a huge sort of undersold part of the
filmmaking process is literally how did
we get from A to B to C without feeling
like we're always like um you know in a
in a car that's coming to the breaks too
bad yeah yeah you know that's been an
interesting thing to kind of be reminded
of how important transitions are in
visuals telling well especially when
you're because I've never adapted
something I've always kind of started
from scratch even if I've kind of you
know been working from the idea of a
genre I've been working from elements of
other things I've never taken something
that's this and tried to make it into
that yeah it seems and I'll I mean we've
I read a book that I love usually the
last thing I might I'm never thinking
how can I make this a movie just because
that process seem so daunting to me of
deletion the division is daunting but
it's really interesting because I think
it's the simple it's a it does mirror a
process that I like to go through when I
have a screenplay and I'm about to start
shooting Morasca prepping which is that
I like to read the script in one sitting
and and take notes on the moments where
my interest isn't engaged you know
literally take notes on kind of check in
with my own sense of engagement with the
scene to scene transitions and like you
know life of the scenes and so I'm kind
of doing the same thing with this book
where I realize oh you know that chapter
it just doesn't figure in my imagination
of this potential limited series right
and that's been an instructive way to
have to
Rochat and to kind of give myself the
break that I'm not trying I'm not trying
to crack a code so much as just check in
with what interests me about the
storytelling I'm trying to remember who
I was talking to as a writer director
who works with the same editor every
time and they were saying that before
they shoot they will sit down with their
editor with the scripts and go through
it as if they're cutting the movie oh
wow which is intense and also I thought
why haven't I been doing that that's
absolute that's that's that's brilliant
that's a really interesting idea
I actually do something not similar but
I I do do that process but with my
composer actually and and basically we
talk through the script in terms of a
kind of musical shape and with that
conversation in mind he starts writing
music before I start shooting does that
does that ever affect the script though
do you ever lift stuff out do you ever
change things do you ever adjust or is
it more attack for him because it does
affect the script because there are
certain things that he has created
destroyer is a good example where he
created
musical lines that to me were so
inspiring that I kind of understood a
sense of emotional catharsis that that
that had to happen and be backed up at
the script level right which isn't to
say it wasn't already there in the
script level but I think it just needed
to be amplified whereas the invitation
which is where we started this process
the musical gestures that he was
creating were so skeletal it kind of
helped me understand how sparer the
movie might afford to go if that meant
you know yeah totally yeah yeah yeah
yeah do you how much when you get in the
Edit room with your different movies I'm
sure it's different for each of them but
how much have you done big picture
shuffling like in terms of how much do
you unlock your brains aware oh this
what if this sequence went before this
sequence and kind of the big timeline on
the lunar flute how fluid is that for
you I think I think one of the things I
am always fighting against in myself is
a sense of taking things at face value
and sort of falling into an unhelpful
linearity when it when it comes to just
sort of what my expectations in a script
already are and so it takes me some time
generally to say oh my god that scene
needs to be 45 minutes before or I would
say the one thing I'm getting much
better at is watching something and
knowing right away oh we lift let's lift
that scene entirely let's just do it and
you've actually given me some great
advice along the way early in a cut
where you've just been able to
articulate something that isn't as easy
for me to articulate when it comes to
saying I'm just not engaged here and the
moment I hear it from somebody else that
I know and trust
it helps unlock for me that moment of
understanding something's not actually
clicking the reason I'm not
racket is because it's not engaging me
so for that reason it's important to
show stuff to people I mean the other
thing that I find really useful about
liftings even if you're like god I know
we need that scene but it feels but
think of how it would flow without it
first of all it even though it always
pains you to like lose something
especially there's good stuff in that it
always feels so good to hit that button
and suddenly it feels like you've hit
the gas on them and just like when it
hops over when it works it's just a
great feeling but also even if a lot I
mean you're shocked the amount of times
that you realize the thing you needed
from the scene was something the
audience doesn't actually need and
they'll make that leap but if that's not
the case taking it out and experiencing
the film without it and realizing what
you are genuinely missing from it can
let you go back to the scene with a
refocus of what is the essential kernel
of that scene what is the one thing that
thing has to do in order for it to earn
its place in the movie which can be
really really useful yeah I find that
that is actually the part of the process
I like the most if you have an open
enough sort of communication with both
your editor and your team of either
producers or trusted friends or you know
whatever that audience um however you
show it to people in those early phase
phases if you feel like that's a sort of
compassionate enough exchange and
constructive enough exchange it's so
interesting to see what that kernel is
and sometimes at the script level and
even at the shooting level and even deep
into cutting you think it's oh I need to
understand these pieces of information
but really what you need is just to see
a person touch another person's hand and
grab you more you know and so it that's
been the you're right that it's um
taking stuff out is so interesting for
so many reasons
because who demands that you experience
the movie again afresh right such an
important part of the process and so so
difficult
to keep doing yeah yeah yeah completely
do you have any I mean when you're in
the thick of production because when
you're writing you can always kind of
air for me at least I can always kind of
step back and look at the outline and
take a breath and reorient myself and
then kind of you know seeing the whole
picture same thing with the other thing
when you're day-to-day with production
do you do you have anything that you do
during production to kind of help
yourself not get lost in the forest it's
a kind of showing updated they're
shooting out of order just kind of
keeping yourself oriented you have
something that you do and you know
either way there it's in the morning I
was pretty corny but I share it with my
actors too I just say that I really want
to be like I want to be here with you
the actors and so sometimes I just like
to say can we just like take a second
take some deep breaths and just like
feel the energy of our being kind of
travel into the ground through our feet
through our toes can we just you know be
here together and then when I watch a
scene I'm trying to be in that state of
groundedness you know for once of a
better word and I'm really trying to pay
attention to like is my mind wandering
am i distracted by you know visual
imperfections am i letting the shot take
over something that's happening in the
scene and if the shot takes over that
means something I need to be paying
better attention to getting to the
essential emotional thing in the scene
and so for me it's a little bit about
just like this idea of like paying
attention to how I feel as I'm watching
something as if to say am I feeling
anything while I'm ready you know you
can watch something and it can just be
kind of dead and you don't know why you
know it's dead right right all right
yes I'm
yeah so much of the job on set that's
first of all that sounds awesome I want
to do that until everyone said connect
through their feet that sounds really
cool I don't know if I could pull that
off you've got like a cool you've got an
energy where I could I would believe you
I feel like my actors would just laugh
at me if I told them that but I feel
like you get away with it like you can
do that I started doing it while you
were saying it I started like putting my
feet on the ground I'm here with you
right now but that you're right so much
of I mean this this is more kind of like
specific onset but the you know so much
of your job onset is when you after you
call action when you're looking at that
mod or waiting next to the camera
looking at the scene or however you're
doing that of clearing out the making
sure that you can snap into being an
audience member and as pure away as
possible and and clear out any
insecurities you've got about and just
kind of to create to experience that as
purely as you can and then to create as
pure a connection as possible gene what
you experienced and what you then
communicate when you walk after you call
cut and that's yeah that's that's
something that's like a spin for me this
is all just a really dumb little
practical thing that sounds really
really obvious that everyone probably
does but during the day when especially
when you're moving fast on the rush day
or whatever and you're shooting out of
the board they're always you you say
okay next we're doing this scene taking
a moment for yourself to read the scene
previous to that scene and to read the
scene after that scene is something that
for me again that sounds super super
obvious but for me on the day in the
midst of the set you're like okay I know
what we're doing it's so easy for me to
kind of like ignore that and just start
started into it but grounding myself on
where we're coming from and where we're
going before and after the scene that
we're actually shooting first of all for
me helps a lot in talking to the actors
because giving them that calm
text is always really helpful but also
for me just reminding myself it kind of
then if I know on either side it kind of
shoots out into the rest of the movie
and I have a better sense in my head of
where the scenes places in the movie
when we're doing it yeah it's funny
because that that process is so crucial
and it is so easy to overlook it and
funnily enough for me when there were
those couple of years where I was just
doing a lot of television back to back
but on shows that I think were pretty um
you know often visually kind of
demanding or had very specific styles or
a very specific kind of tone it was
really important in that short prep
period and in that short shooting period
to do exactly what you're saying and
it's sort of taught me the value of
[Music]
checking in with what comes before and
what comes after and again thinking
about sort of okay how do i how am i
getting into this scene and how am i
getting out of it ideally you know again
in that sort of transitional way I think
so much of film is determined how you
feel about it it's determined in how the
transitions are happening
yeah the handoffs and the dramatic and
I've seen and grounding those not in
terms of okay we can wipe off of this
with this shot or this would be a cool
visual transition but grounding it in
terms of storytelling whose perspective
leads into what's going to start
happening in the next scene what is the
thing that's what is the spark that
started in this scene that's gonna light
the fire in the next scene and ending in
a way that emphasizes that thinking in
terms of storytelling storytelling yeah
I wanted to ask you a question because
last night as a family we watched Frank
Oz's dirty rotten scam scoundrels yes I
know you're a big fan of the movie and
we had a lot of fun watching it but as I
was watching in it and particularly by
the end I was like oh my god this feels
like a foundational movie for how Ryan
was just thinking about Brothers Bloom
am i I mean oh my god totally
yeah the tone of it the
the tone of it the the even like even
the relationships in it but also the
globe-trotting element of it it must
have been a fun movie to watch right now
also she was like oh my god but Franco's
in general I mean he I feel like people
don't talk about him enough as a
director but to it between that and
Little Shop of Horrors which i think is
one of the all-time great movie musicals
it's just a fantastic adaptation his we
just watched Bowfinger the other night
my god that movie is fantastic I mean
literally I was making girl fight and we
were cutting at the old sound one in
Times Square me and plumbing my editor
and friend and we were just so I think
we had to cut and be finished with the
whole movie in ten weeks be fed like be
mixed and so like sleeping in the
cutting room and like it was quick it
was insane but so many movie theaters in
Times Square and it was like almost a
midnight showing but I was just like we
have to stop and remember that the three
the two movies we saw in that like kind
of wasted State of Mind were
paradoxically Pather Panchali which was
mind-blowing and actually instructed
because it wasn't available yeah
beautiful beautiful film and anger and I
I and the fact that both Inger was this
like loving comedy about I I remember
literally laughing until I was crying
and then just crying is such a great
movie I mean the dog feels so good I
mean it's just it's the absurdity of it
is so pleasurable well and also he's you
know Frank is one of the is he's a
comedy director who who visually engages
within thinks visually and tells the
story of visually it's not just kind of
like sitcom coverage he
a really highly stylized visual comedy
director but this style never gets it
always leads to the lab he always helps
with the laughs and yeah he is the best
man and such as we dude that's funny
when you cause one of the things during
production I do do every everytime I
when I go home at night even if it's
just 20 minutes of something I always
try and watch a little bit of the movie
hmm when I'm in production just because
that's the other thing I feel like when
you're in the thick of kind of the
carpentry of it it's easy to forget what
the impact of the finished product on
the screen is going to be and so
watching something that doesn't have to
do and isn't anything to do with what
you're making even just watching
something that is going to make you feel
yeah connect and and just remembering
this is what the movie does that for me
is always really helpful yeah and it's
funny because I'd like to say
you know particularly when you get a
bunch of devastating notes from either
your financier or the studio or you know
dear friends most distressing most trust
you and love you the most it can be so
painful and I sometimes say you know
yeah it's like you know making movies
it's not brain surgery it's harder okay
you know because sometimes I just feel
like oh god it's so hard to make a movie
work and so that's a great idea to be
watching movies as you're making a movie
to sort of check in with what's working
and and I mean I find as I get older as
much as I love um stylistic panache I
ultimately it's all about faces like
what's happening on an actor's face what
kind of story is being told by a great
actor you know that yeah it's so true it
realized that kind of like and I feel
like anyone who kind of because I feel
like a lot of a lot of directors have
kind of I know for me like I the first
stuff that you're doing when you're a
kid is like making shorts and it's not
involved in acting it's all about the
shots it's all about that you know and
Kyle let's do this cool thing what if we
put the camera in a sling shot and flung
it you know and it's all about copying
the cool technique and I think you
always hit I feel like I don't know at
least I you have to hit a point from
experience where you realize that if an
actor is doing their job and if the
story is clicking the actor is selling
it that nothing else really met
everything else is great if you can make
it work for it but that really your only
job on set is making sure that happens
making sure the actor has what they need
to give you you know but talking about
faces though the other thing that and
again this is a really specific thing
but for me because onset generally I I
don't I usually don't even have if we
have a video village
nobody's there usually usually I just
like yeah you're on set and I like to
have a little portable monitor that's
generally probably like pretty small
like that right you know and be that the
shot is yeah the shots working but you
want to be on set with the actors you
can engage with them directly the
problem it really is a thing that even I
find myself falling into even with it
was a big problem when you had video
taps with film where it was like a fuzzy
image even with HD you're looking in
that small monitor the temptation to go
into close-up constantly the temptation
to forget how much expressiveness can
come from an actor in a full shot with
three people in it and then that's still
gonna read and so for me specifically
watching older films watching like
Michael Curtiz movies or watching films
where they didn't really do close-up
coverage as much but realizing you still
get them seeing these films were like
they're playing these incredibly
emotional scenes where somebody is
breaking down it would be something
where I'd be unthinkable today to not be
a big close-up for it and it's a wide
three shot in the restaurant or
something with the person in like
three-quarter angle with almost their
back to you it's like having it still
completely reads as an audience member
you lean forward and that's something
that that's good to kind of remind for
me to remind myself up constantly you
know Oh totally it's so funny because
just the other night we're trying to
watch a lot and just to stay you know
stay stay fresh stay Lively yeah and we
were trying to show me CHEO for the
audience
our 13 year old son The Big Lebowski for
the first time and it was an incredibly
pleasurable experience and obviously
there's so much about that movie that's
really pleasurable but the sort of comic
fulcrum of the movie to me in a funny
way is less Jeff Bridges who I adore in
the movie but John Goodman and there's a
moment at the end when when you know the
ashes of a body fly into their faces and
it's a disaster where then Jeff Bridges
blows up at his
at him and John Goodman they stayed for
the first time the camera sort of hangs
back and does not cut and you just see
John Goodman full body slumped
apologizing over and over again and I I
felt this like tightening in my heart
because I realized oh my god the only
way I could understand the power
emotionally of this moment is to be
stepping back and seeing him full-body
and skiing wind in their hair and cliffs
behind them and this kind of existential
tragic comedy found them and you know
that's it's just so nice to watch movies
with a sense of like that's how they do
that you know it's the thing it's not
the close-up it's it's the white one of
the wider shots were ever gonna see of
these characters right okay and
emotionally it's it's a yeah it's such
an interesting experience it's really
cool we've been we returned Grammy we're
watching a lot of stuff too but every
night when weird like sitting down to
watch something it's like being in the
video store like neither of us want is
tired we neither of us want to make the
decision and so we got this app it's
like and there's a bunch of different
types of it but the app is just called
random you can you can create a list in
it so we created this list of all these
movies that we both want to see and then
you hit you hit the button in it it
generates it and that's what you're
watching that night oh you gotta commit
to it that's interesting we had a
slightly more analogue plan in mind
because we have that hundred hundred
film collection the Janus films
collection oh yeah and I think it's four
DVDs to a page yeah and Phil was like
what if we just go page by page and
choose one movie off of those four and I
was like you know what I'm gonna get I
go through it there was at least one
movie on each page that I would so
that's kind of that that but that's
to do random I love it I've been working
my way through that Bergman set that
they put out that's great
incredible I know I'm due for another
Fanny and Alexander reviewing one of my
favorite movies of all time so good so
good so good let me ask you a question
back to dirty rotten scam scoundrels and
thinking about knives out and the
Brothers Bloom looper is a little harder
for me to know exactly what the kind of
generative you know cinematic influences
are for you but life and Fincher ensure
interesting okay
interesting so when you come up with
Brothers Bloom when you come up with
knives out are you doing that from a
place of knowing you want to do a
certain kind of movie or like what comes
to you first like the scene the some
emotional arc like how do you for the
for the writing you mean like the story
I mean you know like brothers okay it
was like watching dirty rotten
scoundrels last night I was like I
wonder if that was one of your favorite
movies mm-hm and you wanted to tell a
version of that kind of crime caper do
you know what I mean I know it was you
know is less specific than that it's
more con men movies in general and so
it's that it's dirty it's a house of
house of games it's you know it's just
kind of you know cross and
double-crossed kind of movies and also
just kind of tonally like Ricky J like
his body of work in general and the fans
it was out there's also kind of a thing
with like the the second movie you get
to do where I like the first movie is
always kind of like this or not always
but I don't know generally the first
movie is sometimes a very tight focused
thing because you've had to be working
on and shaving it and getting it very
economic and then if you're if you get a
chance to do a second one very often
you just want to throw your arms open
and like fit everything you love into
one movie so we're though that's how I
felt so that was like oh my god I get a
second chance okay let's try this if
everything in there and brothers boom
for me was kind of like that was just
trying to fit everything I loved into
one movie but it did start with the idea
of doing a conman movie and for me it's
always kind of a free-floating thing
about be fun to do this type of movie
that does help me kind of have a
grounding genre wise but then it never
gets started until there's some
emotional element that I can actually
connect to or that I have some personal
stake in or remain angry about or
something that can be served by that
genre and I and it's when those two
things click together that the writing
process actually starts when I figure
out oh this would be a fun thing to do
and and boy that is also a really
interesting way of talking about X or
exploring you know this thing that I'm
yeah that's a bit with you know with
looper the salmon that's one thing that
is consistent with for me is that's how
at least so far all the movies ever then
have started even with the Star Wars
movie similar thing there's got to be
something where you there's a level on
which you're engaged and I guess for me
that's what I call theme I think a lot
of writers
I know writers who push back against the
idea of theme as like I'm not writing a
message movie or something for me it's
not a theme is not like you know do your
best or something that you can write on
an inspirational poster the theme is not
it's the question that the movie is is
that every scene in the movie in some
way is wrestling with me it helps give
the whole thing kind of a crystalline
focus it helps me know okay yeah for me
I can't imagine writing without theme
but again that's how I specifically
define theme so no I
to agree with you not so much as a
writer because I haven't been writing as
much as I used to but in terms of
approaching things from that really
general question that you hope starts to
have some kind of snowball build which
is what is this about
right you know and you want to be able
to apply those questions to scenes
sequences and like some sense of you
know the totality of the thing
absolutely yeah
buying those like the rug ties the room
together I see Paul popping up together
yeah hey I'm back
are you ready for some questions yeah
sure before we go to questions I just
want to chime in and say yet the dog in
the stilettos good one of the funniest
things and I mean whenever whenever I
learned that somebody hasn't seen it or
they have seen it and they're unsure
about whether or not to like give it its
proper I'm just like the dog so we have
a lot of questions I'm gonna try and
group them sort of thematically and
let's get this endemic questions over
first Jack asks how do you think the
pandemic will affect the indie film
industry fate says how do I continue
networking and frantic vibing when
everything has come to a standstill in
Los Angeles and Rob for you Ryan says in
light of recent events do you think your
next couple of projects I guess this
applies to both you really your next
couple of projects will feel more
independent like your indie days with
smaller crews possibly remote
conferencing for production meetings and
editing yeah that's all good questions I
wish I knew the answer I guess we're all
that's part of what's you know kind of
so crazy and scary about all this is I
feel like we're in such unchartered
waters right now I feel like no none of
us really know how this going to shake
if there are things
going to go back to normal for the next
thing are we going to be like you said
having to like you know to figure out
yeah but I I don't knows and so I feel
like that's kind of the cloud that we're
all in right now
yeah I definitely think and I don't know
what normalcy is gonna look like or
rather when that's gonna come but I I do
think things are gonna change I think
just the nature of a film set has to be
re-examined and I you know I don't think
anyone's gonna ever look at the craft
service table again thank God by the way
thank God all due respect to every craft
service table I've ever interacted with
they're going to have to be different
from now on and I think just the health
and welfare of every single crew person
and actor is going to have to be taken
into account in a different way we
cannot keep asking people to work when
they're incredibly ill it's something
you see on film sets all the time and I
wonder if that's gonna have to change
actually like you know maybe it means
it's changes to how we ensure films I'm
not quite sure but it just feels like we
have to have a different kind of
approach to the health and welfare of
the like film making body of your movie
you know and then the bigger interesting
questions of kind of like how how is
this going to affect the movie at their
independent film in general which is
kind of the bigger thing because it's
going to affect movie going is the fact
that people aren't going to the theaters
right now is that going to snap back or
are we going to see a fundamental sea
change in terms of in terms of that
which is very scary to think about for
people like us who love going to the
movies I mean that those are the things
that we're all kind of you know trying
to gaze into our foggy crystal crystal
ball and figure out I mean I had a
question about
just the way we've adapted to this new
normal right now is anything that we new
ways of working that you think will
still carry over like you think people
just do more zoom calls
and I don't think so I that's it is the
one thing both in the in terms of that
and in terms of movie theaters to me I
feel like it's similar to going to
restaurants
I feel like all of us are coils that are
being sprung tighter and tighter right
now and the fact that I am literally
having dreams at night about being at
restaurants with my friends when that
coil is released and I hope this is the
case I'm good that we're gonna go to out
to see more movies than ever we're gonna
and I hope that's and I don't know just
the idea of being able to be in a room
full of collaborators and be
collaborating on something sounds like
heaven right now and I hate
pre-production so the fact that that
sounds good to me but I don't know the
answer is I in our two opinions about
this mean anything I will say my daily
fantasy when I think about what I miss
right now and I'm in the privileged
position to say this that this is what I
miss I miss the opportunity to like go
to a double feature at a data theater
and see a couple movies in a row and
meet a friend for a meal in a restaurant
like I literally think about the day
that that that I can do that and I look
like my heart swells and you know in
terms of movies I do think it I mean the
downward pressure is is staggering right
now I I think we're probably gonna lose
some really consequential and
significant theater theaters potentially
but in terms of moviemaking
I actually think indie film has a chance
to to be a real exciting possibility now
because we're not putting entire crews
on airplanes to go all over the world
we're not our footprint is small
I mean I do think there's a possibility
that the first movies that get made and
up and running after this is all over
are Indies
that's my hope anyway I mean I don't
know what it does to the larger
community and the larger economy of
indie filmmaking but my hope is that
there's some real some real
opportunities after all of this is over
but frugality will thrive yeah I think
making something cheaply is gonna be
valuable again yeah okay change of topic
horror movies Molly says Karen would you
ever direct another horror movie and
Doug says to Ryan what's your all-time
favorite horror movie and is it a genre
you want to tackle Karen I'm really all
your movies are slightly horror movies I
mean that's a highest compliment I can
imagine yes in fact most of the movies
I'm I'm developing right now or um you
know attached to direct have a component
of horror in them if not outright horror
films you know it's not something I
engineered for myself but yes I keep
wanting to make horror movies to be
scared of these days yeah yeah I mean my
favorite horror movies I had to be
honest it's it's a genre I think because
my family was was really religious when
I was growing up and I wasn't allowed to
see a lot of intense stuff and so it's
not a genre I have a grounding in
emotionally and it's also kind of like I
have a lot of friends like Karen
included who are you know incredible
filmmakers who engage with their genre
and make movies that just amaze me I
don't know whether I have I don't know
it's not something that's ever for
whatever reason drawn me but but then
there are films like alien like the
first alien I under the skin I would
count as a horror movie of sorts and
that's one of
my top 5 of all time under the skin so
so there are things there there I guess
it depends how you find horror I suppose
but yeah yeah
question from Molly how much does
literature inspire your works or ideas
for both of you mm-hmm that's an
interesting question I read I read I
especially now I'm reading a lot and I
definitely feel like there are moments
when I feel you know a kind of ecstatic
emotional engagement with something when
I'm reading it and it's it's exciting to
ask myself why do I feel that and and so
frequently it has it's it's kind of
ephemeral it doesn't have to do with
visual connections or or or what it is
I'm seeing it's something more sort of
intricately built you know in terms of
the emotional quality of how a story is
being told and that can be really
instructive I think as a visual
storyteller but that's also just because
I like to read what about you Ryan I
don't know do we do we talk about books
all that much I don't know we don't we
should let's start talking about books
more yeah yeah I love reading I've
always been the big reader and it's a
huge for me in terms of it's a lot of
what you said it's not even like reading
something and saying wow that would make
a great scene or it's almost the
opposite of that that's something that
can get you out of your head in terms of
your own work and fill back up that well
of inspiration with something that
because it's disconnected from what you
do or what you're supposed to be working
on yeah it can fill up that inspiration
bucket inside you so know for me it's
it's it's it's huge about working in TV
but also kind of franchises Antony asked
you Ryan about working on Star Wars
last year I'm stepping in to take
control of the story that someone has
already told up to that point and then
leaving it for another person to tell
and likewise come with with TV where
you're directing if it was a movie
you're directing like movie and then
leaving it alone so how do you approach
that uh well I mean I I think because
for me the original trilogy is so like
inter-gold so like I'd feel like I it's
something I just grew up with so deeply
that the shape of the story and the
shape of the way the second chapter
works in a trilogy like that it was
something that I had a good a good for
me at least my own sense of and felt
solid with that but then honestly it's
it's kind of I mean youyou kind of just
have to kind of what we were talking
about on set with watching an actor
perform on a monitor when you're taking
it when you're taking in the story
that's been going to be handed off to
you like of the first movie in this case
you want to just be as pure an audience
member as possible and so that that can
kind of the things that excite you about
the story the things that engage you the
things a thrill you the element the
thematic elements are like oh my god how
did all of those things are like coal
that you're putting into the furnace for
the next way you know what's going to
fuel the next one basically and and
what's going to drive it forward but
then it's it's that driving itself
though is is not dissimilar from any
other kind of storytelling you know it
seems like it'd be something where
there'd be more math involved it doesn't
feel that way at least it didn't for me
when you're in the middle of writing it
it just kind of feels like I don't know
it feels very organic it feels like
telling a story the way you would you
know any other way I guess and that's a
very muddled kind of answer but it's it
it's it's it's a strange organic process
I guess it's hard to kind of define yeah
and I think I mean for me I am actually
really thankful
television for helping me with a process
of I want to say a kind of distillation
process where it's important for me to
understand you know what a show for
instance has already done before me how
it sort of made its mark how its created
its language and then to find ways for
me I liken it to you know sort of
figuring out how can I speak that
language and still be myself speaking
that language and all of that in a in a
kind of micro level gets back to what I
think Ryan is talking about which is
this idea of finding the moments the the
sequences the emotional builds that just
engage me the most and finding a way
into kind of making those the most
special or the most kind of attended to
with within an episode of TV I remember
coming into coming into it real quick oh
they're coming into Breaking Bad like I
I in terms of this is something I'll
frame in terms of directing the actors
but I think it applies to the question
like I kind of thought coming into it
the first episode I director was in the
third season I thought Bryan Cranston
and Anna Gunn and Aaron they're not
going to like I didn't assume that there
I would need to actually work much with
them as actors because I had this I'd
never done before I had this idea that
well they know their characters better
than I they've been living these people
this is something where I'm coming in
and just facilitating it and getting on
set and realizing when you have good
writing it's taking the characters into
new uncharted territory with every
episode with every scene with every
moment and the it has to feel new and
real and frightening to the actor is
stepping forward scene by scene and
that's what makes it a good show and the
same is true with writing even if it's
serialized it needs to feel thrilling it
needs to engage you as a story it needs
to work on that fundamental level and
not just
you know kind of tag basis or not just
continue what's you know it's got a yeah
no it's a movie for an audience it's got
to engage them and satisfy them and
shock them and Surprise them and thrill
them and all the things a good story
should do yeah it was the fly the second
episode of Breaking Bad you directed
that was at first that was artist yeah
for that - you did you kind of oh no no
they ya know they offer it you you don't
get to choose they they send you a thing
and say this is the one you're doing and
I was like that's that's mean that's one
that everyone talks about it kind of
divided audiences do you keep have you
followed the sort of feedback so that I
remember at the time kind of you know
seeing some of it and I you know yeah I
mean I mean one thing about that I mean
first of all I felt incredibly lucky to
get that specific episode not because
this is going to be crazy or divisive or
whatever but because it meant I realized
it meant I was going to have a
concentrated amount of time in one
location with Aaron and Brian and for me
it was like for myself it was a master
class of working with those two actors
and getting to focus and do kind of the
equivalent of a play with the two of
them and it wasn't a lot of traveling to
different locations it wasn't dealing I
was trying to keep it visually
interesting but the lar the work was
really just doing working with these two
incredible actors and getting a chance
to have a very concentrated experience
with the two of them and for me I was so
thankful that I got to I got to do that
and Moira and Sam who wrote the episode
had such a great script and yeah it was
just it was it was kind of heavenly but
I mean that's you know it's enough it is
a bottle episode an it's an episode that
in the middle of a season that is
chugging away on this narrative it stops
and examines the people so you know I
feel like the you know a lot of people's
frustrations with it at the time might
have come from that you know but I also
feel like it earns it and the
talking about Moyer and Sam and Vince's
work not mine it earns it and in the
context of the whole season I think it's
a really necessary piece I think it
stands up to repeated viewings I mean
the reviews I read from just viewers on
IMDB I hated this episode and went back
and watch it like I totally get it now
as one of my favorites it really
requires repeated viewing it stands up
to it I think I had a question about
working something like the outsider when
the subject matter is so grim I'm have a
family how do you kind of just put
yourself in that mindset and you forget
this might not be it sure you'd want to
watch yeah it's a funny thing I've um I
I've been having to kind of check in
with myself a lot about the stories I
the stories I like to watch versus some
of the stories I like to make and and
it's it's there's been a kind of growing
dissonance between those two things and
I'm trying to understand you know how I
can get a little closer you know how I
can get those two things a little closer
together
um because sometimes I think I put all
of my anxieties all of my dread all of
my terror about the world at large into
my work it just feels like a useful
place to put it but now I'm I'm actually
starting to question that a little bit
every now and then so I'm not I might
it's a to answer your question Paul I
can't completely answer it yet this
leads on to the next question from Jenny
and she says to both of you have use
sense check character development and
relationships and keep them grounded
when they exist
in extraordinary or fantastical
situations or settings
yeah I mean I to me I guess I would say
this just because both and and I I'm not
gonna speak for you but knowing that
both of us have done different genres
I just think you're always trying to
find the regardless of all of that
architecture you're just trying to find
the truth of the matter you know the
you're just trying to make something
real and not blink and you know not
flinch from your own you know you you
have to be as invested in it as you
expect your audience to be so you have
to you know I don't know I mean it's
like I I don't know why I think of
looper or Star Wars as more demanding in
that regard but I would just think those
are the movies where you have to feel
like this is really happening
and well the invitation I would I would
say isn't I mean all your movies but the
invitation is something where you have
almost like a you know almost like a
hyper concentrated version of that where
everybody is making extreme choices as
the things go on and the movie really
hinges on you believing those choices
and you're not feeling like not having
the horror movie feeling about where the
why don't these idiots just do this you
know you're right but I think it for me
it's no matter what kind of movie you're
making it starts obviously with the
writing it starts with the I think one
thing when you're writing is you always
have to genuinely be able to put
yourself in the shoes of any one of the
characters and know why you as that
character are doing what you're doing I
think you ideally you should do what an
actor does with their part with every
single part in others also the key I
think to writing good antagonists good
you know quote-unquote villains is you
have to especially with them be able to
put yourself in their shoes and
genuinely identify something in yourself
that relates to their to their flaw
that's making them do the things that
they're doing but that is also what
leads to you know because the ultimate
check is going to come when you're on
set and your actors come up to you and
say why am I doing this if they're good
actors they'll always and sometimes you
have an answer for it
and sometimes they say okay I can play
that that makes sense and sometimes and
these are the moments where unsaid
especially if you wrote the thing you
got to be really honest with yourself
and you got to realize I'm the reason
you're doing that is because I need to
get this information across and that's
not a good enough reason for you to be
doing that so let's figure out another
way for it to happen
and yeah you got you got to just kind of
nail yourself to that to that on this
day all the time except when you cheat
and then and then just cheat yes the
words of Ricky Jay at some point you
just got to ask for the money both Tyler
and Curtis are asking about the
difference between working on indie and
then move into studio projects and I
will kind of also add that when you're
going from a smaller movie to a bigger
movie keeping yourself grounded and you
know the thrill of getting star wars but
the fear of getting star wars or in your
case crime going from girl factor influx
like what is the mental preparation to
keep yourself grounded and what else you
need to do to prepare yourself for what
you don't know about how to make a movie
like that they you know taking the
knowledge from an indie movie and
filling the gap to be able to make to
pull off Aeon Flux or last year I think
there were I mean Karen had actually
been much more interested to hear you
talk about this just because I feel like
you had because I Star Wars was the
young flux but that was literally the
second yeah feature that you coming
straight off a girl fight which was like
a brick sighs young B whereas I had the
Brothers Bloom and then I had looper the
effects element I had kind of more of a
ramp up into it you I think had much
more of the vertigo-inducing thing out
you're seeing a lot more of today with
these poor filmmakers right out of
Sundance with one movie who are suddenly
getting thrown you know art that
aardvark man three to direct and like
tossed into the dust into the midst of
it I mean so I makes curious in terms of
your yeah is it all to say please you
answer yes
I mean I think we've discussed the the
painful aspects of it ad nauseam but I
would say that the you know what I've
really taken away from that whipsaw
experience is how important it is to
like pay attention to your gut when it
comes to the storytelling like where do
you feel like the story really lives for
you
why aren't why are you doing this why
was I doing it that was something I was
trying to stay in touch with and I think
at the time particularly since it was
only my second movie and I was
relatively inexperienced I wish there
were more moments where I I could say
helped me um but I think that the
particularly 15-20 years ago the ID and
before the ideas of a director
particularly a woman saying help me just
sounded like the wrong move and now I
see as a just an older wydad wiser
person I hope that asking for help is
the director's job it's kind of one of
their best most interesting jobs is
getting to go to the talents and the
intellect the gifts of other people and
have them sort of collaborate with you
toward a toward a final sort of
execution of something and I think I was
really afraid of that I probably at the
time and it didn't serve me very well
and the movie was sort of tortured
anyway but um but you know like really
checking in with the actual story at its
most elemental I think you need to do
that with a little movie and you need to
do that with a big movie and it's just
the stuff around it expands or contracts
I don't know did you feel that way on
last Jedi well I I think but I'm very
thankful that I had done even three
movies before that and that I felt like
I saw it for me
was a much smoother transition and I
also was it was a very good situation I
had great producers both in ROM and also
Cathy and all the folks at Disney were
terrific and just supporting and so I
but I think the yeah it feels like the
feels like the number one thing is just
we're kind of in a weird way like I mean
I think what you said is really really
apt that first of all that being not
feeling like you have to go in there and
pretend like you know everything about
this bigger process like I would i'm
star was that's one thing I would start
at DARPA department head meetings like
saying okay this is my first time doing
this so I need I'm going to ask a lot of
stupid questions and then not being
afraid to ask a lot of stupid questions
but I think the key thing is exactly
what you said also I'm just repeating
what you said less articulately is
confidence there's so much confidence
you know I actually don't know this you
know enlightened me helped me and just a
lot of sort of a kind of balance in
oneself so there's a hundred percent
what the key is is is is confidence and
I feel like that's something that you
know it luckily that's something to some
degree you can sometimes fake if you
like you're always taking it a little
I'm always faking a little but also then
ultimately give a feeling like I don't
know I fit I think my fear if I had gone
into a big movie right after brick is
first of all I would feel like I was
lucky to get the job and that's a
feeling that you can never feel as a
director you have to feel that you're
the captain of the ship not like you
have to be dictatorial or be an [ __ ]
my coffee just fell on the keyboard the
man that but but you have to feel that
you are you have your hands on the wheel
you can't feel like you're lucky to be
invited to that dinner and you have to
make other people happy and yeah that's
so it and just kind of ignoring the fact
that it's a bigger thing and just saying
preaching it the same way you approached
your smaller movie creatively I guess
Brett
asks a similar question for you Ryan
about knowing when it was right to go
from your shorts to like it's time
really for a feature for brick and I
mean there's no real you're ready when
you can get your first movie made
there's no kind of calculating like I've
reached the point where I feel mature
enough to make but no it's when you when
you can sucker people into writing you a
check to make a movie [ __ ] do it you
know because because you're never ready
you know and you're always ready if you
can do a couple more questions
a lot of these questions about
recommendations people asking
recommendations for reading mystery
books if you anyone you have favorite
mysteries you're reading mm-hmm you know
I recently recently there's this great
bookstore in New York called the
mysterious bookstore so basically they
do these terrific it's this guy Otto
penslar and he runs a mysterious
bookstore in New York and he does these
editions of mystery classics have kind
of been out of print and through that
John Dixon Carr is an author that I
recently discovered in the mystery realm
and Carr was kind of in the golden age
of detective fiction he rode around the
time of Agatha Christie was starting out
he was kind of in that era he's a little
bit more kind of mounting a game of
mousetrap with his plots they're a
little less like Christie tends to be
very character-based and that's kind of
what I loved about her car is a little
more there's a locked room and there's a
mirror that faces this way and there's a
thread that's burnt you know it's a
little more like that but they're
fantastic and his detective dr. Gideon
fel is this fantastic character who
this massive man incredibly British he
based it on I didn't he'd we think base
in mind forget him on was a Chesterton
GK Chesterton might have been any I
might begin that Robbie based him on
another author that he was friends with
and it's just a wildly entertaining so
the crooked hinge is one that I can
recommend from if you go them if I look
up the mysterious book bookstore in New
York which is a great place to support
right now anyway they're a independent
bookstore and buy a copy of the crooked
hinge John Dixon car CA are are any
books to recommend you know right now
I'm actually reading a nonfiction book
called trick mirror by gia tolentino
it's essentially about coming-of-age in
the Internet age and it's ten essays I
believe and it's just beautifully
written
incredibly somewhat grim depiction of
what it means to be in today's world
where the notion of the Internet has
completely overtaken every aspect of our
daily life and our imagination but I
find I find it pretty pretty exciting
writing really worth worth reading trick
mirror by gia Tolentino okay and then a
lot of people asking and if I stand a
question right there of you know what
what are you watching and
recommendations whether it's a TV show
or a movie and it can be like finally
catching up on a classic or hidden gems
you could dig deep what are you watching
what would you recommend I'm gonna just
say to anyone who is a member who is
watching this right now who does not
have the Criterion channel get the
Criterion channel and literally you
could spend day and night just watching
what they
programmed for April and still not not
catch every great thing I mean it's just
april alone
it's like columbia erimar its toshiro
mifune festival it's 70s movie style
icon movies it's like I mean it's such a
it's such a like embarrassment of riches
I can't even name one thing I would just
say go to criterion channel become a
member support criterion Channel it's I
think $10 a month yeah that means it's
it's just crazy what a resource it is
all the old movies yeah it's just insane
someone had a question for you about I
don't know if this is one of your
favorite movies it's one of mine but
they asked you to talk about come and
see which is a criterion a little bit
about that oh yeah I just um it's a war
film I think it's the greatest war film
ever made
it's a Russian film and I recommend it
actually as a as a kind of hybrid genre
film for me I see it as like a
foundational horror film but it is also
rooted in you know the real events of
the invasion of Bella Russia in world
war ii and it's some nightmarish beyond
most of our ideas of what our films can
deliver on in terms of nightmares but
it's so beautifully beautifully made
deeply unsettling challenging to watch
but but really worth it have you seen
that Ryan oh yeah get the thousand-yard
stare no it's a that's absolutely
incredible
and yeah check yourself emotionally
before you watch it it is a it's like
today cut Follies in the way that it
truly truly gets you in a way that is no
joke
like make sure you're in a good place
and have some yeah
Raburn staying out whether it's amazing
you feel like the main boys looks at the
end of the movie like I can see what he
looks like that he looks like an 8 year
old man and made by LM Klimov who was
married to Larissa Becca your fan of
hers right Ryan who said his wife
Larissa should get Co you know [ __ ] Co
maybe I'm just not I'm not connecting I
know your friend of other Russian movies
right like that's never said it
sure yeah absolutely yeah I recently
discovered Tarkovsky and so and not
discovered
I knew Tarkovsky existed but I recently
visited Tarkovsky for the first I had
seen Solaris but stalker was really the
one that I watched stalker for the first
time and it really really really got me
and then I read and then I read Jeff
tires book which is about stalker which
is called it's called what's it called
rumah it's called a book about a movie
about a journey to a room and anyway
it's yeah Tarkovsky is absolutely
absolutely incredible
I've been watch the other night actually
speaking of directors that I'm kind of
like trying to make headway into we
watched The Grapes of Wrath the John
Ford version and I mean talk about a
timely film but God Gregg Toland shot it
and it every single shot you could put
on your wall and the visual storytelling
in it is just unbelievable it's
absolutely incredible Grapes of Wrath I
think also on criterion no maybe not
maybe not maybe not we may have had to
iTunes that anyway one of the few movies
the Russian authorities allowed to be
screened in Russia back in the day makes
a less jealous that the poorest people
in America still had a car other pigs
Ryan for me
uh.what also been watching recently
Karan I recommended that Louis Malle
documentary to you that's right we
watched from God's country and I'm so
glad that we saw it Paul both both Ryan
and I recently watched a Louis Malle
documentary called God's country which
is still on criterion Channel and it's
just a portrait of a farming community
in Minnesota in the late 70s and then
returned six years later after the farm
crisis Reagan's farm crisis has really
kind of devastated the community and
it's it's just beautiful filmmaking just
effortless you just kind of I couldn't
quite figure out how he was doing it as
I was watching it but it's really
beautiful it's really oh yeah and then
and then speaking of speaking of deep
cut classics on Hulu they have 12
episodes of this now-defunct game show
called spin the wheel hosted by Dax
Shepard and executive produced by Justin
Timberlake and it is a it is a harrowing
harrowing analog for late stage
capitalism it's a really fascinating
show absolutely it's it's Emmy it's dumb
it's just a big wheel that they spent
there's one thing you do they spend they
have this big wheel and you spin it and
there's dollar amounts but they pick and
Dax Shepard obviously is like a lovely
charming guy and he's great as a host
but they pick they pick like true like
good people to be on it and they tell
the story of how this person runs a food
bank or this person saved a bunch of you
know students on the bus when there was
a bus crash or this person the the
genuinely good people and then the
nature of the game is this giant cold
unemotional wheel that ends up by its
very nature dangling large amounts of
money in front of the people and then
cruelly just through nothing but
circumstance chance taking it away from
it's it's weirdly like it's but it's an
update the other night we watched an
episode we were just like this is too
sad we get we have to stop watching that
we had kind of like a moment as if we
were watching come and see or something
tragic right also on criterion channel I
would be amazing incredible there may be
a documentary about it eventually that
has to be the probably the most
left-field recommendation we're gonna
get this during this period well thank
you both I hope you'll come back soon
and do this this has been a coffee talk
on film independent check out more
information at film independent all
memberships open to everyone we are back
next Thursday a little slightly earlier
this time with Robert Eggers take us
inside the making at the White House
wait for now I want to thank two
fantastic guests today Karyn Kusama
current thank you thank you guys this
was fun
and Ryan Johnson Thank You Ryan thanks
Bob thanks everyone thanks for asking me
Karen I hope you make it to the end in
the wheel nobody makes it to the end of
school
thank you both great to see you thank
okay bye nice I guess
[Music]
you